[Music]
there is war raging in anna and sasha's
homeland
the two are now refugees in germany
as i stand here i think of my husband he
died early on in this war
their future is uncertain
how are they adapting to their new life
in germany
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anna and sasha have been living in
berlin since fleeing from ukraine
they found accommodation with a host
family
by a stroke of luck they managed to flee
the russian bombs
they got out of chennai four weeks after
the russian attack on ukraine
they are safe here
but their thoughts are still with
ukraine and their family and friends
there
my friends
my classmates
i can't bear the thought that they
didn't have the chance to escape even
though they wanted to
that's what's terrifying
and
even though i'm doing well here
the war completely changed their lives
anna was nearing her high school
graduation sasha worked in a call center
on february 24th their hometown chinev
north of kiev was bombed for the first
time
it lies close to the belarusian border
where russian president vladimir putin
sent his soldiers into the city
they bombed us from day one
we moved to my mother's house the first
week and hid there
truly the whole time we were holed up in
the basement
[Music]
managed to escape despite the daily
attacks
now they live with martin and cornelia
young enrich
the couple drove a rented bus to the
polish border to pick up the refugees
humans are social beings if someone
falls down next to you you lean down and
pick them up again
it's completely natural
and it's heartwarming to see how the two
are managing together
but how they're coping with it and just
getting into gear
[Music]
getting into gear that doesn't happen in
germany without facing some bureaucracy
today an ancestor have an appointment at
the social welfare office
they're hoping to actually receive
financial assistance for the first time
today
catherine a family friend is helping
with the paperwork
i hope this works out
there's nothing missing and really
nothing can be missing
i've already been in contact with the
people from the district office a lot of
back and forth and they've already
opened a file for them everything should
be okay
they've been waiting for this
appointment for weeks
are you registered with the state of
berlin yet
yes could be that i have it with me
they're missing the confirmation the
interpreter helps them search through
their emails again
and luckily they track down the right
one
it's a bit nerve-wracking making sure
that absolutely nothing is missing
we have a great feeling
because as far as i understand it we'll
receive the money directly afterwards
and that takes the pressure off
are surprised how quickly everything is
going
germany has removed many bureaucratic
hurdles for ukrainian refugees
the pair can collect their money
directly it's about 350 euros per person
which they'll start receiving every
month
[Music]
i'm glad everything went so fast
we're exhausted
all that running around
and then you stand there waiting and
wondering whether it will all work out
or not
i'm feeling hopeful now that everything
went so smoothly
to integrate even better ann and zachary
have signed up for a german course
a church congregation organizes weekly
lessons free of charge
after a short introduction they start
practicing
what is the name of your wife your
husband
is
it's a little bit difficult
but it's okay
we are teach
teaching
so we are students we want to study
germany
payetta
are among 60 000 refugees from ukraine
now living in berlin
they often see ukrainian flags across
the city a sign of solidarity
today the two are on their way to the
ukrainian embassy in berlin
they want to lay your roles for anna's
father
[Music]
he died early on in this war
he died five years ago while fighting in
eastern ukraine the war has been going
on since 2014
since russia's annexation of crimea
[Music]
it's good that there's somewhere in
berlin where ukrainians can come to
express their grief and leave it in this
place
the children who have been killed are
commemorated here with drawings candles
and flowers
[Music]
bye
[Music]
a few weeks later sasha and anna want to
show their things
they're preparing a meal for their hosts
catherine is learning how to make a
traditional ukrainian beetroot soup
a ukrainian cooking class today sasha a
master classic
[Music]
this is our ukrainian national dish
it really fills you up
today we're making it with lots of beans
to replace the meat but a real ukrainian
borscht is cooked with meat with pork
ribs
the borscht brings back memories
anna has not seen her family and friends
for weeks
some are still in chennai if others like
her have fled abroad or are still in
transit
i want to see my grandparents and eat
grand
grandmother's food
because
it's
the most beautiful thing in the world
and
meet my friend
and talk about
how they're feeling and everything is
fine or
maybe something is terrible
and just talk
are settling into their new lives
they get along well with their host
family and know that they can stay with
them as long as they want
delicious
very tasty
it feels like we're having dinner with
our own family
we're already totally comfortable with
our german family it's like being at
home
[Music]
the mother and daughter are slowly
finding their bearings in berlin
together they're discovering a new
country a new culture
before they fled they'd never been
outside ukraine
since they've arrived they've grown even
closer together
anna feels so comfortable she can even
imagine studying here right now she's
wrapping up her high school final exams
online
i want to
to come back to ukraine to see my
family members but i think about living
in german
for my life
in the future
because i really like this country
i'm not at the age to completely
overturn my old life all my relatives
are in ukraine and my house too
i want anna to decide for herself
whether she wants to stay in germany or
return to ukraine
but i want to go home someday when the
war is over i will definitely do that
but at the moment they have no idea how
long that will take
[Music]
you